this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsay show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice
dr john dolone ramsey personality
best-selling author is my co-host today
as we talk about your relationships your
mental health and your money it's the
ramsay show where we talk about you all
day long
right in front of you the phone number
is triple eight eight two five
five two two five
alexandria starts off this hour in
columbus georgia hi alexandria how are
you
great dave thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
well we will have my husband and i will
have a paid off 135 000 in debt and on
december 15th wow
how long did that take
well
we probably did about
three or four years of dave ish
so
and then the we really buckled down this
last year we probably got 75 000 of it
done just then wow good for you well
done yeah
yeah so wish we wouldn't have done dave
ish
as long as we did proud of you
good um my question is now
um
we just found out that my husband has to
have thirty thousand dollars worth of
general service of course he does and of
course
we got done paying off debt so we were
going to start our emergency fund
but do we
pause that and treat this like a debt he
doesn't have to have it tomorrow
probably mid next year um so what is
your household income
well that's also good news it will go up
to 165 000 on december 15th
um
well
you know we have the question is is this
an emergency
or will it become one by the middle of
next year
and if the answer is yes then it's an
emergency fund issue you're funding baby
step three now that you're debt-free and
you're just going to put an extra 30 000
into baby step 3 or from baby step three
is funded you're gonna save up for the
non-emergency item as soon as that is
done so you're gonna be there by the
summer uh i have a question though
you don't suddenly need thirty thousand
dollars worth of dental surgery unless
you're in a car wreck
right
um his is a combination of parents that
decided he didn't have to go to the
dentist once he proved it when he was a
child and um shoddy dennis work that he
had when he was
younger so it's one of those things that
we
didn't want to face so is he hurting
i'm sorry is he hurting in pain um he is
not we have we have taking care of those
issues
so this is
preventative
and cosmetic
correct yes okay
um i've done a lot of work with dentists
on the business side of the equation
over the years
and um there are some very very very
good ones as a matter of fact i endorsed
several in different cities around
america i completely believe in what
they do but i also know that there is a
um
[Music]
a vast spectrum shall we say of uh care
and uh competency and pricing
and so the the chance of me personally
doing this or someone that i'm writing
the check for doing this with only one
opinion and without becoming a freaking
expert on everything involved while i'm
doing it uh is zero so you need to get
like three more opinions and you all
really need to study this because i
think you've been given a narrative
okay by the dentist
oh it was shoddy work and he never went
because his kids did his mom didn't make
him behave and
well i didn't go to the dentist a lot
when i was a kid i got on my teeth so it
you know
um
but it wasn't because i didn't my
parents didn't make me we just didn't
you know they were just we just didn't
do that but i mean i went some but you
know it's not like today you're down
there every 20 minutes with your kids
but um
the uh
so
yeah i i
i'm just going to verify
that this is accurate
and once i verify that it's accurate i'm
going to put it
somewhere just the other side of the
emergency fund if it's not an emergency
that's
if it's if it's cosmetic and he's able
to chomp down on that stake yeah it goes
after the emergency for a long time now
that's right yeah
so i mean i'm
yeah just to so when we were going broke
i had zero money and we were in
bankruptcy and all this i had a
toothache
so i go in the dentist and he says um
you need 3 200 worth of work done in the
next 90 days or you're going to lose all
of your teeth and you're going to be
walking around like the abominable
snowman basically you know and so
basically that thing
and i'm like dude i don't have 3 200 and
i don't have any credit because i'm in
bankruptcy and
so i guess i'm just going to be
mr just just change my name to mr
abominable right
and um
so uh two years later
uh i went to the dentist again
and uh just to have a cleaning and how's
everything going just fine
and um
how much work have i done uh 30 years
later that he suggested zero zero yeah
um
and doing okay
so i'm i just got a bad guy there got a
bad guy he was trying to make his kids
college payment or something i don't
know what he was doing but
um but that just uh just said uh
dentists and doctors and lawyers are
people too
a sometimes they make mistakes b
sometimes they're not competent c
sometimes they're crooks and so i'm
always going to double check when it's a
lot of money because 3 200 30 years ago
was 30 thousand dollars today right
that's a lot of money and i was so broke
i was just 3 200 you got to be kidding
me i could buy two cars for that you
know so no um yeah
and again that's not a that dave ramsey
hates dentists so don't send me they
don't crap on twitter and and doesn't
believe in dental care and you know oh
my god well some of this sounds like how
do we extrapolate from there but you
wait so long you mean you you bust it
you pay off all this debt you hit this
goal and you've got this carried at the
end which is i've got to get this done
kind of like when you got to go the
bathroom real bad and you're on a long
trip
and then you finally pull over and go to
the gas station and then it feels like
like in that one moment you could have
kept going tim up that moment once it's
you're right by the bathroom door
it's it's coming right you got to get
there it feels like i've got to get this
thing done i got to get it done got to
get when we get out of debt we get our
debt
and it's so easy to jump the gun he's
done all that and then all of a sudden
there's another thing that's urgent that
has been there for ten years ten years i
i gotta go that's what i was talking
about
urgent thing yeah that's what i got
that's what i'm talking about so yeah
just tap the brakes a little bit become
wise make sure that this is accurate if
it is accurate i'm not saying don't do
it yeah um but i don't know
um that many folk that i've ever known
that did 30 000 worth of work that i was
aware of right however they did and i
wasn't aware of it but and it can just
go from we've been doing this for 30
years we could save up over the next
year and pay for it two
let's just go go ahead and get it done
too next thing you know you've put that
on a payment plan oh no no no no no i
got culture it's a zero no no i couldn't
i wasn't suggesting that no it happened
no one would do that after they called
this show
that would never happen
[Laughter]
dr john deloney ramsey chef this is the
ramsay chef
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost
the average family saves over 800 a year
go to puretalk.com and choose the
affordable plan that's right for you
with their 30-day risk-free guarantee
you have nothing to lose go to
puretalk.com and enter the promo code
ramsey to save 50 off your first month
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today paying off debt is smart
saving and investing is smart being
generous is even smarter merry christmas
there's one key to winning with money
that people overlook sometimes and
that's protecting your finances we all
talk about the offense but we don't talk
enough about the defense and that's
where insurance comes in there's 10
kinds of insurance coverage you might
need probably do need most of them based
on what your life looks like and we
built a tool to help you figure that out
it's free and it's called the coverage
checkup and it'll tell you which types
you need to add drop or adjust and we'll
even rank your coverage list by
importance email it till you connect you
with a ramsey trusted insurance provider
so you can get your plan in place fast
donald h wrote in and i like how he put
it he said for anyone who has not
completed this checkup do it right now
you never know when something will
happen and you never want to leave your
family in a bad situation it's free
do the coverage checkup
ramseysolutions.comcheckup
don't let an emergency sneak up on you
that's why we call them emergencies
ramseysolutions.com
checkup our question of the day comes
from blinds.com find out for yourself
why blinds.com is the number one online
retailer of custom window coverings free
samples free shipping and with the doom
promos they run every month you'll save
even more use the magic word the promo
code ramsey
all right today's question comes from
debbie in oklahoma debbie writes my
husband and i are a blended family his
kids live with their mother and it's
been a long difficult road with them
they both dropped out of college and one
is currently not speaking to us the
other has voluntarily limited her work
hours so she's still struggling
financially and doesn't get benefits
years ago we set a number in our budget
for them since i received child support
for my son that i used exclusively for
him
while i'm not against
helping them from time to time i feel
like we've passed the time where we need
to be regularly budgeting money for
grown-ups who don't live with us
especially if they are not in our lives
at all what are your thoughts on this
yeah i'd cut this off today
completely agree totally we're done you
know
done yeah
number one i don't give money to people
who don't speak to me right i mean just
kiss my butt that's ridiculous
um that does not buy you anything it
does not cause anything good to happen
it's it's just a sign of complete
enabling yeah um dad's guilt over the
former guilt money over whatever
happened that caused the divorce is he's
still playing disney dad and they're 27.
yep and that's just bs it's hurting them
well it is the whole situation there
everybody's just allowed them to
continue they're stunted back when the
divorce happened and they're still
living emotionally at about that age
and uh because no one especially
their mother
his ex is pushing any buttons and
so yeah i mean i would just say listen i
love you if you're hungry
come over you can have dinner
anytime just holler at us ahead of time
if we're if we got something on the
stove we'll share it with you we'll
never let you be hungry and you know but
we're not we're not giving able-bodied
adults money we go get a job what do you
think about this dave i i don't like the
idea of i don't have adult kids yet i
don't like the idea of
giving
money to adult kids just as a part of a
budget no if adult kid currently says
hey i'm going to go to college i'm going
to go to med school
you know maybe for tuition or for but
just no your adult kids do not need to
be online it's like it's an allowance
yeah it's just ridiculous
that's the definition of adult yeah
you're on your own
puppy
so i mean you know it's uh
old hard school dad you know
you're 18 years old uh you're either in
college or you get a job and you leave
that's right i mean one of the two and
by the way if you're in college you
probably gotta leave so um
so you're gonna leave that's hardcore i
mean but it's there's there's something
developmentally we we have i've read
several articles and you probably know a
thousand times more about this than i do
about the we've got a group of people
that not all of them not the entire
generation but two too large a
percentage of a generation who their
emotional
evolution their emotional growth was
stunted
by living in mom's basement
and i actually think it goes one
generation before that we have a group
of adults who are using
kids to prop themselves up and they've
created this right like
i need my kid that's where i get my
validation i didn't get it from my
marriage i didn't get it from work i
didn't get it from society i got it from
my kid and here you are you blink and
you look up and they're 25 years old and
you're still sending them an allowance
yeah because there is pain as a parent
when they leave yeah
because you're no longer
you're out it's part of your identity
that's it when your kids become your
identity when their success becomes
validation yeah but but i mean it's it's
healthy that
i'm a dad of us
these are my children that's right and
then when they're
still your children but they're quote
grown children which is a lot just
becomes your yeah yeah yeah when their
their performance on the t-ball field
becomes your values well that's always
been a problem yeah yeah but i'm talking
about that
there's a natural tearing
that the parent
also experiences when the kid moves out
and becomes an adult yeah there's like
oh god and you've experienced how much
easier would it be if i could just throw
500 bucks and they'd stay another month
yeah maybe another month and then you
know what i mean
and uh but yeah
it's it's it's giving a drunk a drink
ultimately although they're not drinking
they're just emotionally immature right
they have not evolved and now they don't
know how to receive they're 27 years old
and they're operating on about a 17 year
old emotional level is that right you've
seen that data oh gosh well it's just
tough to take feedback from a boss who
says i want this report done differently
or the first time you have a
fight with the person you're dating it's
all over and so you know i mean there's
no there's none of that emotional
resilience yeah
and a maturity yeah so yeah that that's
what happens here so yeah you need to
cut them off it'll be good for them is
what we're saying yes
um yeah you know but now uh let me take
let me change that just a second because
i made a mistake i said you need to cut
them off your husband needs to cut his
kids off you don't need to say a
stinking word right because you'll be
the wicked witch of the west my bad
father married this woman and after that
they never helped us anymore no that
that's you may get the blame whether you
do it or not but you need to stay way
back from this and push him out into the
light he needs to be a grown-up push him
out onto the stage and he stumbles out
there and makes the speech
yeah that's and you just stand back in
the wings and give him a thumbs up
that's right that's right thumb in the
back all right
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five hey we're doing
uh as we always do our last live show we
always do uh best doves from christmas
to new year's our last live show is
always the last
day before we go out on christmas break
and we will be doing that on the 22nd of
december and that show is always a
giving show we take three hours and set
it aside
three one-hour shows which we do every
day and and do it all on giving so if
you have a great giving story or
receiving story maybe you've received
generosity or been the person who gave
generosity it's always inspiring to
other people it's not you bragging on
yourself or saying how great you are we
need great stories because it tells
other people how important this subject
is
go to ramseysolutions.com
ask
put giving
in the subject line
and kelly will get back to you and
arrange for you to be part of the giving
show
ramseysolutions.com ask put giving
in the subject i was i was a part of
that show last year that was a that was
a blast man that was the first time you
were starting to poke around on this
stuff right yeah i mean i was that
i think we've been about august through
through december there but that was cool
is to hear the stories of of
the successful giving opportunities it
was just rad it was cool to see it's
it's um
it's inspiring yeah it is and and
because you you find the uh
the creative ways that people work and
god works through people
because it's never uh cut and dried it's
never a template
it's always some
cool twist on something that but how how
fun is it to be creative about how to
bless somebody now you're using like art
and creativity and
blessing i saw one the other day on the
on the internets with a group of people
they do it every year they get a group
of friends together they all go out and
everybody's required at the table to
bring a hundred dollar bill on top of
their food
and they tip the waitress and there's
about 15 of them and it's just it's a
thing they do as a group of 15 friends
go out they have 1500 bucks they get a
500 tip on whatever their dinner is and
they just seeing their face as she got
like it was such a just a cool thing and
whatever fred came up with that idea
genius right i just love that idea that
is about as good as it gets right there
i love it
so fun
so very fun dr john dolone ramsey
personality this is
the ramsey show
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personalities my
co-host on the debt-free stage in the
lobby of ramsey solutions jim and mara
are with us hey guys how are you hi
great how are you dave welcome where do
you all live we live in colombiana ohio
near youngstown oh wow okay very cool
welcome to nashville
so uh how much debt have you guys paid
off it's a whopper it's uh 303 thousand
dollars
or 303 678 dollars good for you and how
long did this take
took us 68 months
okay and your range of income during
that time
we started out at 55 000 right
oh yeah i was just graduating graduate
school and uh jim was working and so
and now we're at 178 000. yep okay very
nice what do y'all do for a living
i'm a speech therapist
and i run the business side of an
architecture firm okay
so did you pay off your house or did you
have a crazy student loan crazy student
loan crazy student loan all right
graduate and five year degrees a begging
that big one yeah yeah how much of that
for 304 000 with student loan debt 289
289 000.
all speech therapy uh it was pretty even
oh was it most of us yeah my degree was
in uh architecture so i actually went to
you know i did the thing where you go to
the best possible school and it's
private and
uh four plus one yeah right
uh i'm uh yep yeah and uh it was about
180 for me wow
yeah
so as soon as she gets out of school we
get the income way up then we jump on it
with both feet and go yeah yeah okay
how did you guys tie into us what's your
story overall tell us your story it
actually started whenever i was
traveling around the country uh working
for a technology startup i ended up not
actually using my degree
in my most of my career
and so i
read the book and i actually started
with entree leadership once i heard you
on the radio
to apply those principles to the
business
and then we both dove into the total
money makeover and
yeah and we we were working on it
separately
starting in 2015 um
starting to pay our loans off and we got
married in 2018 and so then we've really
ramped it up since then
to really get it all done and paid for
wow way to go combining your income
really really helps oh yeah anyone
that's listening
big shovel and just get after it yeah
yeah and it i mean we
have kind of really been a good team
throughout the whole thing and making
sure that we're making we have our
bi-monthly budget meetings and uh
we duel it out sometimes um but but
we've stuck together the whole time and
that's kind of what's been
that's the big breakthrough yeah without
question so if i asked you how many go
ahead i was gonna say you guys make a
great
salary
surely there's people where y'all work
that look at your cars you're driving
and say what are you doing yeah yeah
yeah they you know you got the questions
when are you guys buying a house when
are you doing this um why don't you just
get a lease you know all those things
and um
yeah so
we're still renters yeah yeah we don't
own a house wait a minute
you're renting and you haven't died yet
no correct it's been a miracle every day
i thought if you rented you just
spontaneously combusted at some point
because you can't live like that wow
it's it's great yeah no maintenance you
know as you can see i just got i've got
a problem coming tomorrow that i'm
paying for yeah exactly yeah
homeownership is not cheaper yeah uh
that's the answer to that question it is
a better investment long haul but it is
not cheaper
so guys that's incredible so when people
ask how did you do that what did you do
to pay off 304 000 in 68 months you
cleaned up a huge
student loan mess
and one of the things you tell them is
you you said we work together so what
else do you tell them
um i think it's i mean sacrifice you
know we
uh especially like during covet i work
in work in healthcare i was working
saturdays when i could um for a little
extra pay i was
uh jim was you know i was uber driving
bartending i was doing everything on top
of my full-time job and
you know those little extra
payments that you make and you know as
you lay out the debts and the baby steps
as you start to see them sort of
disappear even though it was a large
principle for for both of us
that really helps your momentum
and uh the sacrifice is definitely the
big and we've had a lot of support from
both of our families i mean i lived i
had to live at home with my parents for
like seems forever it was like five or
six years for me to clean up my mess
because of my income with
the uh the balance of the student loans
that i had nothing feels better than
graduating from a really fancy school
with a graduate degree in architecture
and moving back in with your mom huh
yeah and that is yeah
i i you know and i and it was hard
because our
we have a lot of incredible friends but
it felt like
a lot of people were moving on with
their lives and taking these next
chapters and we were sort of trying to
we really it was hard and everybody had
that it is hard uh
and people don't
understand they look at you like you got
one eye in your head yeah but now you're
now you're moving with jet fuel it's
gonna be a whole different ball game
yeah have you all had the
the the paycheck come in where you have
no mortgage i mean when you've got no
student loans the paycheck comes in and
you just look at it and say oh oh it's
incredible yeah yeah it's pretty good
here i mean
world wide yeah how much money you're
gonna have saved in 20 minutes is
amazing i know yeah we already got our
emergency fund done we we actually paid
it off faster than we thought yeah this
past may so yeah yeah a couple months so
it's i mean it's incredible once you
start going how you just pick up more
and more momentum and congratulations
you're going to be there in 20 minutes
you know it's going to be a just a
complete flip but very very fast now
yeah congratulations i'm proud of y'all
you guys are amazing what a rockstar
couple we couldn't have done it without
you guys so thank you for everything
thank you well you didn't pay it you did
your show kept us going the whole time
we listen to you all the time thank you
it's our honor if we can walk alongside
people like you guys so uh hey we got a
copy of the baby steps millionaires book
it comes out in january but i know a guy
we're gonna get you an early release
copy in a few minutes here and you'll
leave with it today and of course the
total money makeover book as well for
you to give away maybe you can get
somebody else on this journey you guys
have climbed a really high mountain as
the first order of business in your
relationship and that sets you up to be
able to climb any mountain anything that
comes in front of you no obstacle is
going to hold you guys back from this
point forward you are really going to be
baby steps millionaires very very
quickly and you're going to be in a
position to really help and really do
anything you want to do from this point
forward so absolutely that's our goal so
proud of you guys very very very well
done all right it's jim and mara from
youngstown ohio area 304
thousand dollars paid off in 68 months
big but student loans 55 000 to 178 was
the income range during that time count
it down let's hear a debt-free scream
three
two
one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
that is how that's done boys and girls
oh man you gotta love it
you gotta love it
303 that's a lot of money 289 000 worth
of student loan debt and
you know that's that's a medical degree
yeah that's a uh a lot of things and
so though you know you know who that
that that
this debt-free screen was for someone
that is watching right now
that thought this couldn't be done
that's right or for someone that's
listening right now that thought this
couldn't be done because that is a
mountain
yeah and they did it and i'm looking at
a couple who
by all external appearances still likes
each other and they've rented they still
like each other they haven't bought new
cars
they still like each other you know what
i mean so they said the key was
sacrifice that's
all these illusions like well our
marriage can't make it if we don't do
that that's bullcrap yes you can if you
if you get committed and you work
together you can you can you can do
anything if you do if you're committed
and you work together it's just stinking
amazing and they're they're man they're
amazing there's a lot of personal power
right there on that stage did you see
all the emotion out of an architect yeah
wow
that's incredible well there's that yeah
but the you know it it just illustrates
because
someone listening right now has got you
know 180 000 100 210 000 worth of
student loan debt and they're not a
doctor or lawyer and they not a medical
doctor or a lawyer and they're thinking
oh well there's just i'm just gonna have
this forever
it's overwhelming and they gave up hope
and this
particular moment this particular debt
free screaming this was for you whoever
you are out there is for you
and uh it means you can do it by the way
and you should do it
and you should start to
day this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality
number one best-selling author of the
book redefining anxiety
is my co-host today open phones triple
eight eight two five five
five this is the ramsay show matthew is
in boise idaho hey matthew how are you
hi mr ramsey hi dr delonie thank you for
taking my call today sure ma'am what's
up
uh so i was in a training accident a few
years ago i'm now a 100 disabled vet
uh considered homebound
and
so
kind of a two-part question i want to
know
how do i
live life and build wealth on a fixed
income
at age 26 versus you know
usually most people don't have a fixed
level until much later
and if i should due to the
crazy market right now of used cars and
the fact that i
don't really leave my house often if
it's a good idea to
sell my
uh
car
and use it to pay off
all the debt i have right now
wow
well matthew um
thank you for your service
i'm sorry for the
the pain you've endured uh what is the
nature of your disability sir
um
i
in an accident i broke everything in my
legs and my back
so
it's a lot of
mobile you have mobility issues
yeah are you in a wheelchair
no for thank god i can walk
it hurts but i can walk so what is
homebound you've been determined to be
homeboned what does that mean
this sounds like a label or a diagnostic
of some sort what does that mean
yeah that's what uh the veteran affairs
consider me okay i am able to leave the
house like i do my grocery shopping
i go see my brother
uh when my parents come into town and
visit i pick them up from the airport so
like i do leave my house but every step
is painted
yeah yeah okay all right
man i'm sorry yeah that's tough so how
much is your disability check a month
uh they just upped it so it's gonna be
three thousand seven hundred and thirty
dollars okay
okay
all right and what were you it was a
military all you've ever done
no before that i uh
pretty much worked for best buy most of
my time i started as a salesman i got
into
a supervisor role
and then switched over to logistics
i want to go back to school so i changed
back to sales
my store ended up closing and i had
trouble finding a job and then that's
when i was like well
army will pay for schooling so i
went and joined the army now in your
disability package uh they will pay for
more school will they not
i believe so yes yeah i think you've got
some additional gi benefits and um
that's cool all right now uh
i'm gonna be
in delicate because i'm looking for
answers i in talking to you i don't hear
any
uh mental issue at all uh it sounds like
your whole thing is you just were in a
horrible bone crushing accident
is that correct
pretty much um
i
it has really affected me like i do see
a
counselor every week that i talk to to
discuss things oh yeah that was a
traumatic event but you don't have any
like there was no brain injury there's
no brain injury or there was no you
you're not mentally deficient in any way
you're other than the fact that you're
just the normal depression from this
trauma right
as far as we can tell yeah okay all
right
all right so um
because that goes so here's the thing
i just answered this the way i would
answer it if i if i woke up in your
shoes and i've never been in your shoes
so i don't know how this feels
uh and to be very blunt with you i'm a
complete wuss i can't stand a hang nail
and so i can't imagine the pain
issues that you're dealing with
and so me giving you advices is
ridiculous in a sense but i'm gonna i'm
going to anyway because you called me so
um i have been inspired as i've watched
people over the 30 years i do what i do
uh
find a way
to utilize the good parts of their life
to have an awesome life when they've got
these limitations and you've got this
tremendous limitation now
uh but but but i'm also talking to a
very bright guy
and so if you decided to
do some kind of
business from home
with the computer
uh or with the telephone the guy i'm
talking to could pull that off i think
absolutely you could you know you could
be a world-class computer coder you
could sell stuff on ebay i don't know
what it is i i just think that the guy
i'm talking to could do a lot to add to
this income and you might find something
where you end up making 200 000 a year
and having the having an awesome
financial life
in spite of
the the medical and the pain that you're
going to face probably to some degree
for the rest of your life
uh unless some kind of huge
breakthroughs occur or something in that
field but but you that that card is
dealt that that ship has sailed so now
i'm trying to figure out with what i
have
what can i make what can i do what can i
be and maybe you're a world-class author
and you just sit and write maybe you
become known as a poet laureate i don't
know uh pain sometimes opens up those
parts of the brain uh and allows you to
do things that other normal humans that
don't have super
uh superhero powers can conduce so um
i i have no idea but i have met so many
people that are in your
situation
who
beyond compensated and became uh just
inordinately successful and so i would
keep your car and i would start thinking
about what my next career is and i'm
going to send you ken coleman's uh you
know career assessment on what it is you
can do
and of course you're going to line that
up with the physical um
uh
limitations and uh but i i don't think
you're
constricted to 3 730
from 26 years old on no i i think
there's that moment where you're in a
dark season you got to grieve what was
and what you're hoping would be you got
to own what happened and then
man
the sky is really the limit it's about
you can open up the blinds you're going
to let people in dave i'm glad you said
to keep the car
i want you to go out and
to the best you can
go be with other people
whether that means hey we're going to
meet at such and such we're all going to
grab a drink at some such and such place
get the old guys back together you're
gonna meet new friends you go to the va
and you be one of those awesome guys who
goes back and welcomes new people who
are coming to the va who experience
accidents whatever that is
you're gonna find some healing in
connection and that's going to help turn
some of that light back on that has been
snuffed out you got to get a new mission
and the new mission is i can
and like they said i don't care what
that is it could be anything new mission
i gotta go back to school thank goodness
the the thing's gonna the g.i bill's
gonna pay for it i've gotta get some
more training i've got i've gotta i've
gotta and i'm gonna make it happen yeah
and and
then you'll be the guy that's featured
yeah on on the magazine comeback story
yeah you know i mean you'll be that guy
i'll buy your book
you're an awesome guy man
you know when i was on fox business a
thousand years ago
uh when that network first started we
stopped and did a feature on a guy that
was uh doing landscaping for me
and uh he was like 60 years old at the
time and uh he jumps out of the
landscape truck jumps up into a bobcat
and takes off and um
uh two percent prosthetic legs
and he runs a landscaping company he's
driving a bobcat i mean like 30 miles an
hour across my yard you know and so i'm
like hey dude i got to talk to you what
happened and he was in the railroad and
uh working on the railroad working on an
engine and a train rolled across and
took both his legs wow and he was like
20 years old and now i'm talking to him
like 40 years later and he's running an
uber successful landscape company i mean
you know multiple employees jumping in
and out of stuff i mean you know now a
different situation than this young man
has in terms of the this young man's got
different limitations than he had but
i'm just people like that just they're
just inspiring to me aren't they amazing
i can't even i mean i can't but you
still you go wow and because it just
tells you it takes away
you're going to be the guy that takes
away the excuses for people that don't
have all the able-bodied people man out
of excuses because of people like you
yeah like you are getting ready to
become that's who i want you to be and i
i can see that for you
and so no you don't you don't build
wealth on 3730 you build belt on middle
wealth on who you're going to become
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
hey guys this is james senior producer
for the ramsay show did you know over 18
million people listen to the ramsay show
every week and a lot of those people
listen on one of our 600 plus radio
stations across the country
to find a station near you head to
show dot com
[Music]
is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality number one
best-selling author of the book
redefining anxiety is my co-host today
he does the dr john dolone show which
has millions and millions of listeners
on the podcast version of it and uh of
course you want to tune into that where
he talks about mental health and about
relationships and boundaries boundaries
might be a good topic this time of year
uh because you get to see your family
this time of year and so there you go
just like that hey you want to talk
about your life and your money that's
what we're here for triple eight eight
two five five two two five anthony is
with us anthony's in kansas city hi
anthony how are you
hi great thank you gentlemen for uh
everything you guys doing for taking my
call our pleasure
i am 49 years old financially stated um
have no debt have a mortgage
300 000.
my mother uh recently uh passed away
left us with
a set of an
annuities
and
all together they're about 400 000 in
annuities you had a caller last week who
you recommended taking the
um an actual annuity over time um no i
didn't
oh okay
versus the lump sum no i said take the
lump sum versus the annuity over time
okay take the lump sum yeah and then do
you know if there's a way or
would you recommend taking the lump sum
asap before any other tax laws take
effect yes
okay um and then the last question
get it out of there pay off your house
yes good um and then last question do
you know if there's any way to defer
this money to for example to have it
transferred to my
uh i have a two-year-old son um have it
transferred to his name instead of my
name so i don't have to pay tax on that
no there's not
not not to my knowledge you could check
with an estate planning attorney or a
tax attorney to get uh more competent
professional advice than i'm giving you
this might be worth what you paid for it
here on the radio brother but um but to
my knowledge there's not any way to move
that you've got the inheritance and
there's no inheritance tax on an annuity
but you're the beneficiary of the
annuity that's what was named on it and
so simply cashing it out um it's not
going to be subject to tax when you cash
it out
uh shouldn't be
you should be just a beneficiary like a
life insurance policy right
i believe so and that was my question is
that but since i'm the beneficiary
listed i'm the one my brother and i
would be the ones to
benefit from that you get the money and
then the money goes into your estate and
you own it and then however you can
transfer it from you to someone else
which is what you would have if you got
the money as a bonus
from your workplace or something be
exactly the same thing it's just your
money there's no there's no generation
skipping of a beneficial interest unless
she had named your kid the beneficiary
instead she named you the beneficiary on
the annuity so
um now just take the money straight out
fast as you can get it pay off your
house there's no taxes on it so
um shouldn't be anyway unless i'm
missing something in the story
so thanks for the call man open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five elia is with us in riverside
california did i pronounce that right
is it elia
elia
elia olia i'm right here give me one
second okay
hi i i'm here can you hear me yes ma'am
is it aaliyah or elia
it's alia i'm sorry ellia elliott i got
one of my strike three i'm out okay
ellia all right cool how can we how can
we help ellia
first of all you're a blessing thank you
so much i praise the lord for you guys
you guys are so amazing um my question
is um i'm going through a divorce we
have an eight and five-year-old
uh we have a home um there's no judge
involved in regards to property yet
i have um 10 grand cash at home
um i have student loan debt of 78 000
i'm not sure whether to put
that money into the debt
or if i keep it for a rainy day since
we're going through a divorce
um and my husband now wants to sell the
property i was trying to keep it because
my kids are so young we've moved so many
times they really want to say
i don't know what's going to happen i
don't know if he's going to let us keep
the house if i'm going to have to buy
the house or just completely move so my
question is what do i do with that 10
grand
i'm so sorry
it's hard to go through this well
it is but you know god is my protector
he's my comforter and he's going to
provide i just need to make wise choices
on my end that's a good point
um
what what do you make a year
um praise the lord right now about 70.
okay
and what is owed on this house
uh about 226. okay
which means you can't really afford that
house darling
correct
so right now the arrangement we have is
that he's paying child support by paying
the mortgage which is 1800. so he's been
paying the mortgage as child support
that was an agreement that we had on the
court yeah
that doesn't that doesn't last i don't
know still have to raise the children
so um your children
are are going to be better off being in
a stable financial situation than they
are being in that house
okay
and that's not what you wanted to hear
today
but i if i were in your shoes i would
sell the house and i would get an
attorney and i would get the get the
divorce papers finalized
here's the problem okay
um
sometimes folks going through a divorce
um
are trying to be nice
and are trying to say well we're gonna
you know i'm not gonna be unkind i don't
want you to be mean or unkind but once
you determine the marriage is done
once he determines he's done
at that moment in time
a divorce changes a marriage into a
business transaction
okay
and this is now about a transaction it's
no longer about feelings there's a lot
of feelings involved okay a lot of anger
a lot of hurt a lot of betrayal whatever
those feelings are they're all there but
you've got to treat this like an like a
trans a business transaction and you
guys are half but doing your business
transaction right now
there's no judge involved and he's doing
this and he's doing that and maybe he
will do this and maybe he'll make me do
this and all of that sounds like
somebody's doing a bad business
transaction to me
yeah okay
and usually it's because somebody
doesn't want to call it
you want to play both sides of the fence
i want to be not together i can't be
together we can't be together for
whatever reasons
but i don't want to go through
all the way to the end and say this
thing is over over over and this is over
over over
yeah i'm so sorry i'm so sorry move get
you a
conservative property to live in your
children will be better off
and hold the 10 grand until all of the
smoke clears on this and there is a
finalized divorce because you may need
it
at some point they're in there
and yeah he needs to pay child support
that's how things work in this world
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host merry christmas america we're so
glad you're with us open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five
if you've had it with living paycheck to
paycheck you're sick and tired of being
sick and tired uh well you can break the
cycle you can take control you need the
right plan and we'll teach it to you
we've talked tens of millions of people
in financial peace university
it's actually about 10 million folks
have been through the claim six million
families or so
and um we've shown them how to get out
of debt how to save money how to uh be
on a budget how to be outrageously
generous how to become wealthy
the average family pays off fifty three
hundred dollars in debt and saves twenty
seven hundred dollars in the first
ninety days
of the class that's an eight thousand
dollar change in three months
it's pretty dramatic
now we'll walk you through the plan but
it's up to you to get started financial
peace university is available as a
ramsay plus membership item and of
course you also get every dollar the
premium version that connects to your
bank as part of that all of this go to
ramseysolutions.com fpu maybe you want
to gift it to someone for christmas
ramseysolutions.com
fpu matthew's with us in boston hey
matthew welcome to the ramsey show
hi uh thanks for taking my call dave how
you doing better than i deserve what's
up um i've got i guess it's going to be
a not necessarily complex question but
i've got
about 1.2 million
in investment debt
um the value is about 2.3 million
um and then personally i've got a
mortgage of
925 000.
my combined family income is 230 000.
i'm i didn't find you until about july
of this year
so i've adjusted i'm technically in
between baby step five and six
so i'm trying to find out i've got some
extra cash i've got about 150
um and a 150 000 extra cash that i was
either going to invest or start to
target and pay down my investment
mortgages gotcha i just don't know which
direction to go well i would begin to
clear the mortgages because that's going
to lower the risk of the portfolio
dramatically
um i mean you got about a 35 equity
position so you got a pretty good equity
position but
um but but i like 100 equity position
and that's what i've got in my real
estate and what i recommend
so i i mean you're sitting there with
two million dollars worth of real estate
paid for plus a paid four million dollar
house
you can breathe man that's a whole
different world that would be pretty
cool and you're about two million
dollars away from doing that so got 150
000 start the process and 200 000 income
um so what is your smallest the the one
point two is how many properties
four five sixty three three what's the
smallest mortgage
uh 253 000 okay
all right there's two things i look at
when i'm look when i'm considering doing
this if i'm in your shoes
uh thing one i look at is i try to work
a debt snowball pay off the smallest to
the largest that's one thing to consider
um the second thing i look at is
something happens in my 30 years of
experience of doing this
when your home is paid off
something happens inside of your soul
that's different than paying off your
rental
so
and there's a bit of a risk management
thing in there too if you if you had to
choose in a horrible situation which
property you were going to lose
because you couldn't pay the bill you
would choose to lose the rental before
you choose to lose your residence
absolutely and so for that reason i
generally put the house at the front
of the real estate
uh to get paid off now you've got a
house that's you almost as much on as
you do four properties so
um that that makes it a little more
difficult but if you had a rental say
somebody called me and they said hey
i've got oh 200 000 on my house and i
owe
180 000 on my rental i would say let's
get your house knocked out
because of risk management does that
make sense
but in your so those those are the
things run through my head while i'm
answering your question
um the principles that i that i kind of
use as my guidelines
um
so if i woke up in your shoes i'd
probably pay off the smallest rental
asap
use 150 towards it and then just take a
bunch of your income chunk towards it
and then i'm probably gonna just take
everything else i can
drag off the table
i'm sorry the next rental property is
uh so it's 253 394. yeah if i pay off
the 253 then roll it into the 394. now
i'll take that i pay off the 253 and
then i would roll it into your home
into my primary yeah i'd flip i'm gonna
knock out that little one just to create
some more cash
because that thing will cash flow like a
bandit when it's paid off
and then i'm gonna do that i'm trying to
create some cash and and then i'm gonna
put that cash with your great cash and
then i'm gonna start chunking on your
house it'll probably take you three
maybe four years knock your house out
and then you'll flip over and start
knocking those rentals out after those
other two other three rental debts out
after that then when all of that is paid
for you're gonna have so much cash
you're not gonna know what to do with
um
i just sat down with our cfo this
morning going over our rental properties
because it's time to start planning
taxes
and um you know when you don't have any
payments on rentals
they they
they make money
that's a lot of cash yeah and so you get
these things all paid off in the future
then you'll be able to buy another
rental with cash pretty quick and then
another rental with cash even faster so
i'm not a real estate i'm not there
why wouldn't you
liquidate those rental properties and
just pay your house off and square up
you could okay you could um
i'm at this point in your million
dollars
of equity in right
i'm reading into this because he didn't
even bring that up
uh and he's
prob i was reading and i was reading
into this that he's pretty emotionally
invested in those into that whole
process
and cleaning it up is an option selling
them all probably not something he's
going to consider doing
that is something you could do or you
could do a partial of that you could
pick one of the four
and dump it yep take that equity and
accelerate this process and then go back
and replace it later or pick one of the
four that yeah the one of the four you
could pick would either be the a peach
that had a lot of equity to make it go
faster or you could uh pick the one you
don't like yeah of the four i got one i
got one you know uh winston rachel's
husband manages hours and we were
talking about it at breakfast in the
morning goes well if we didn't own such
and such an address we'd never buy it
again and i went oh well that's true we
wouldn't but we've got it so we're going
to keep it but if we you know we're
talking about what we're going to do the
next five years it goes we'll never buy
one of those and he named that street
name you know you're right i would never
buy that one again so that that'd be the
one i would sell if i was trying to
accelerate something over on my side i'm
not i'm just buying whole but um but
that's yeah you could liquidate them all
and just 100 pay off everything today
yeah
uh but then you have to start over on
the rental that's right and i'm guessing
he's not going to do that i'm guessing
that matthew is probably
pretty
pretty invested emotionally in this
whole process and so yeah but you know
that bringing that up makes me think
about selling one of them for sure
i like the idea of selling one of them
taking 150 000 cash and suddenly i'm i'm
almost halfway done with my mortgage
over you know overnight and
uh maybe that's too simplistic and there
may be more there's mortgages against
the other ones so it's not quite that
the math not quite that clean but um i i
you said something that was important
there's something about having a paid
off house that
just changes everything
i think um
i don't think when we went broke i
understood the borrower or slave to the
lender because they took stuff from me
you know and i'm worried about the car
being reported i'd go out in the morning
and wonder if it was going to be there
uh and that kind of stuff going through
the bankruptcy and uh so that that
i had a whole new perception on debt
after that and the power it has over you
spiritually yeah emotionally uh
that was one time i experienced the
weight and the truth of that scripture
the second time was when i was 100 debt
free
after i paid off the house and
everything is done
and you do walk out in the backyard with
no shoes and the grass feels different
under your feet and something snaps
there's a peace button
inside of you that flips so do you know
how many americans are
a percentage of homeowners have a
mortgage
uh about half
oddly enough wow i thought it'd be way
higher i did too i just got fresh
numbers the other day about half are
paid off so
i've been
one of my core tenants one of my core
beliefs about psychology is you can't be
mentally well if you are not in control
of your tomorrow and it hit me i've been
here almost two years now
wait a minute if you owe somebody money
you cannot be psychologically well
because a part of your brain knows we're
not in control of tomorrow and if you
don't believe me just walk through a
pandemic wow you find out you're not the
third pig in the brick house you're the
one in the sticks in the
hay house you pay that mortgage off and
you can breathe yeah it's a different
thing it's it's a worthy goal
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
if you're ready to get out there and
find a job you love then you need to
hear this
job hunting can be stressful and time
consuming but my friends at ziprecruiter
have made the whole job search way
easier ziprecruiter is rated the number
one job site in the us by g2 and it's
free so how does it work first go to
ziprecruiter.com
ken
then create a free profile and let their
technology do the hard work by finding
and sending you jobs that are a great
fit and get this
zip recruiter pitches your profile to
companies whose jobs match your skills
and experience if someone from that
company likes your profile they can
personally invite you to apply for the
job so if you're ready for an easier job
search check out ziprecruiter sign up
for free right now at ziprecruiter.com
ken that's
ziprecruiter.com
ken sign up today absolutely free and
let zip recruiter work for you
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage andrew and jane are with
us hey guys how are you hey dave we're
excited to tell our story for god's
glory well there you go i love it man
welcome you guys where do you all live
we live in des moines iowa very cool how
much have you paid off
over 825
grand holy
wow how long did this take it took us
two years and seven months
that's amazing okay and your range of
income during this time 101 k to 291k
wow what do you all do for a living i'm
a cpa and i'm a pharmacist okay so two
824 thousand dollars
did you pay off your house
we actually sold two houses so yes oh in
a way okay all right so there's a lot to
the story okay good good i mean there's
maybe a pharmacy degree in there or
something else but yeah but okay oh my
gosh that's a lot of money
okay very cool so tell me the story two
years and uh seven months and you sold
some stuff what did you sell and how
much and why did all this start
sure so we had two properties in florida
and we decided that it was a great
opportunity to sell those properties at
the peak in florida and uh that those
properties were worth 425 thousand
dollars
so that was part of it
and then we had her student loans then i
had everything i had credit cards
business loans personal loans car loans
i had the rest of it so it was a big
mess mostly on my part so the houses
sold for 425 total yes and we took those
proceeds which was about 150k
and we put that towards our debt which
moved us from baby sub 2 to baby step 5.
okay wow
i meant that the the mortgage was 425 or
the sale price the mortgages were 4.25
okay did you have some other cash you
threw at this as well or some other
investments
we had profited um yes when we sold the
uh properties and then the rest was just
work our income throwing everything at
it okay wow that's impressive guys
very very cool it's like almost y'all
didn't eat for the last few years pretty
definitely a lot of beans and rice
yeah but now you've got an incredible
income you moved from florida and now
you live in des moines
and uh both of you picked up your
careers there and went yes sir all right
very cool so what made you guys get so
intense to do all this
well we first actually heard about you
dave three years ago a little over three
years when we had pre-marital counseling
uh for the first time our pastor had
brought up your program at community
bible baptist church and
we were really interested in starting
our marriage off in the right foot
and so we got married and that's when we
signed up for fpu and started on baby
step one mm-hmm all right very good you
guys wow how did that feel when you
looked at at baby step one and you added
up all your debts and you thought whoa
if we just if we really if we stretch we
can hit a million dollars owed
it was definitely a long journey that
first step i mean it was
didn't seem like we'd ever get there
really honestly
wow
but then the idea comes into your brain
to sell everything and make a big move
well that came later first we sold her
car and i i became her personal
chauffeur okay so that was step one
and uh really from there
i was running a business i was failing i
was living on lines of credit and uh
really what happened we went through fpu
and uh i decided i need to get a shovel
so i got a full-time job as a recruiter
and then a few months later i actually
called you dave and you walked me
through the steps of what i needed to do
to get out of my situation and i was
actually contemplating bankruptcy
because i had so much debt and i had
friends and family and said hey you know
maybe you should just declare bankruptcy
that'd be the easy way out and you
walked me through it davey said you know
what you have a decent shovel
and uh you can get out of this and you
said two years you'll get out of debt
and here we are today two years or seven
months later yeah so so your big big
thank you dave wow that's amazing well
you did it man you took on the you took
on the mantle and went after it yeah
that's impressive very cool you guys
uh a lot going on here oh yeah
there's a lot going on here career
changes
uh redefining who you are yeah getting
married
moving
selling houses i mean this is no small
debt-free screen
no no there was we definitely had some
uh
enlightened arguments about our our
finances enlightened arguments
wow that isn't what we call them in
hillbilly land no we call them fist
fights but it's cool knock down drag out
yeah
enlightened argument oh my
that's beautiful that's a great phrase
all right you have had incredible
success an incredible
uh span of transformation
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of that is
i would say for me i i read proverbs
every day after i listened to your show
for so long and it's you have to put in
the work and my favorite proverb is
proverbs 28 19. we said those who are
willing to work their land will have
abundant food but those who chase
fantasies
will have their their fill of poverty
and i was i was in a fantasy world
trying to run a business and that didn't
work and i said you know what i got i
have to get to work and that's what
really worked for me
wow old-fashioned yeah let's work yeah
yeah it's not get rid of not get rich
quick let's keep getting done yeah so do
you have any other major changes coming
along
so a lot has happened and as andrea has
mentioned we propelled from baby step
two to baby step five which is
saving for a kid's college fund because
we're expecting our first born next
spring
congratulations that's awesome
and if you don't mind we don't know but
we would love everyone on air to know
the baby's gender ah
okay okay
we you're gonna find out we don't know
yeah yeah okay
let's check the envelope yes here it
comes oh this is cool go team girl
all right you ready
sure
it's a girl
she wins
she wins
go team girl team she called it she's a
girl
she might have peeked maybe she didn't
wow
way to go
congratulations
so uh your mom and dad just found out
too yes right now watching
everyone knows now how many uh how many
grandkids have your mom and dad got this
is our first and they're first
this is first oh and it happens all
right
oh my gosh well we've had engagements
here but i never had a baby revealed i
know and look at them they're not crying
they're getting close but they're
holding it together that's fantastic a
little girl trust me after three years
it's been a journey to get here and uh
we just want to praise god it's not us
it's really god that brought us here
today yeah
you've worked your tail ends off and
you've worked a system and you've been
very very intentional you were not
living a fantasy you were playing
grown-up
instead of waiting on someone else to
fix your life um pretty stinking
incredible man and this little baby girl
won't know any of that because she'll
put the work in
yeah she's going to have coming into a
completely different world different
life because of the work you all put in
changed your family tree man definitely
she won't even know she won't even know
well we've got this on video so she'll
have this to look at later you can play
this at a rehearsal dinner
[Laughter]
well
oh that's so fun well congratulations
you guys we're so proud of you who were
your biggest cheerleaders outside the
two of you because you went through a
lot so we went through fpu we eventually
led a class so got to give a shout out
to our supporters our co-facilitators
alina and trent hall as well as my best
friend jan who purchased fbu six months
after we did oh wow very cool and uh
just for me i mean she was my biggest
cheerleader when i similar to the story
before us i was driving ubereats
doordash and uh if you want to get out
of debt she was with me in the trenches
our friday and saturday night date
nights she was riding with me ride or
die
wow ubereats doordash she was with me
friday saturday night this is an hot
date right there yeah
so if you want to spend three or four
hours on a friday saturday night she was
with me every weekend wow putting the
work in i love it so you guys are
incredible you've got an incredibly
bright future we're so proud of you
heroes
very well done wow wow and baby girl on
the way hey we got a copy of the new
book baby steps millionaires for you
that's the next chapter in your story
for sure you're gonna be there in 20
minutes the way you're going and uh and
a copy of total money makeover for you
to give away and bless someone you guys
have been a blessing to us today very
inspiring thank you andrew and jane des
moines iowa 824 000 paid off in two
years seven months making 101 to 291
sold everything loaded up the truck and
moved to des moines count it down let's
hear a debt free scream
three
[Music]
[Applause]
baby girls on the way baby girls girl
power you gotta love it this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today frank is in denver hey
frank welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave how's it going better than i
deserve what's up
thanks for taking my call um so i
recently got debt free maybe a couple of
months ago don't have any student loans
don't really have anything
um
i have about a year's
worth of expenses saved up
um
and i just got the bad news that
i have to pretty much rebuild the entire
front
suspension of my car and it's going to
be about three
three about thirty five hundred dollars
to do it
and um
i mean the car's only worth about two
thousand dollars so i don't really you
know think that's a feasible move but i
also don't wanna you know get an auto
one or anything like that and i'm just
trying to figure out you know
should i find a truck trying to find a
car you know under ten thousand dollars
but it's just it it's hard on him i mean
it's hard finding them especially
something with all-wheel drive so i just
need a little bit of a guidance
okay um how much do you have in savings
um
it's about
up top man i know it's like over fifty
thousand dollars in savings
okay and what do you make a year
about a hundred thousand good for you
okay
so um
you're thinking about spending ten
thousand dollars on a car and your car
was two thousand dollar car but now
needs three thousand dollars worth of
work so it'll sell for
five hundred to a thousand dollars
salvage right
yeah that's that's what i was thinking
about you know less than probably less
than about a thousand yeah
all right and so you got that thousand
and then you've got fifty thousand
because you know three to six months of
expenses is enough for an emergency fund
and you have a year's worth
so that leaves you some money to do
other things with including purchase a
car and you're talking about buying a
ten thousand dollar car right
yeah i don't wanna go over ten thousand
dollars and
yeah well it's just hard i'm trying to
find a car about ten thousand dollars
with um
that has all-wheel drive and that's
somewhat reliable i mean i really only
go to point a to point b um and i just i
haven't found one in the area that i'm
at and i've kind of been looking for the
last week well i mean you just got to
look and find a car dude but i mean
you we really can't put the premise
forth that there are no 10 000 reliable
all-wheel drive cars
we do know that they are that those
exist and
it's an unreasonable premise to say that
that doesn't exist it does exist you may
have to buy one with a couple hundred
thousand miles on it keep in mind frank
you've been driving a two thousand
dollar car
you're moving up five acts
right you know so i don't know all of a
sudden a 10 000 car is not reliable when
you've been running around in this
hoopty and making it just fine until the
front until the front end decided to
drop out of the stupid thing make it a
priority sit down
i've had it for like seven years so i've
done all the maintenance on it so i know
all the you know pretty much every nook
and cranny of the vehicle so that's kind
of one of the reasons why you know when
you if you buy a used vehicle it's at
ten thousand dollars and you don't know
well if you've done all the maintenance
to keep this hoopty running for all
these years you know what you're doing
you know how to look at a car
and figure out if you're buying it you
know something that's destroyed or a
lemon or something i mean you're looking
at the miles uh you go pay to have the
oil change you can even go to one of the
places have the oil analyzed until you
know see how many how much shavings is
laying down there in that in that whole
pan and uh you know you know you can do
a little bit of research on that
particular type of vehicle with that
particular engine and find out you know
the reliability of it but there's lots
of good ten thousand dollar cars out
there that are all-wheel drive and uh
the car market in general is wicked
crazy like a lot of markets right now
it's it's not a great time to buy a car
um so you know it's not exactly like
they're sit you know so there's a
shortage and there's a prices are being
marked up that's a reality but
the fact does remain that with a little
bit of work you're going to be able to
find you a car now i will tell you this
before you go
and overspend or rationalize or become
emotional and do something really stupid
like take out a car payment because you
can't find something
just go rent a car
and rent it for you know two weeks
and spend a little bit of your money to
give yourself some patience
if you're if you're stranded just go
rent your car and that keeps you from
feeling forced into a stupid idea
and um
[Music]
you know and you don't have to rent
something super expensive just rent
something that'll get you back and forth
for right now and let you calm down and
okay the pressure's off because i'm not
riding the bus anymore
and uh and while the other car sits over
there you know it's come if it's
completely laid down and it sounds like
it is maybe it's still drivable i don't
know if it's still drivable just drive
your own for a little bit and just be
careful because the front end ain't much
left of it so
um i heard a little bit of grief in
there dave listen to him describe his
old car
he wants something he knows that car
he's talking about like an old
girlfriend like i knew her and i loved
her
time for her to go man man
gotta let her go there's some grief in
there well yeah i mean they've been
friends a long time seven years
alex is with us in montana hi alex
welcome to the ramsay show
thanks for taking my call dave and john
sure what's up question for you a
question for you about a bachelorette
party hey you you asked the right two
guys we both are absolute experts on
bachelorette parties i can't wait for
this great hopefully you can help
for
sure i am the maid of honor for my good
friend
and she's
thinking of inviting quite a few girls
to her party
and looking at some pnp's price ranges
like 1500 to two thousand
dollars for the weekend
so
just wondering
i don't wanna front
money i don't wanna be the one to
reserve it
unless i have you know some payments
that's fun but i don't really know how
to tell her that or
suggest maybe she wants to put her card
down
um i'm just looking for some guidance on
what i should say i think guidance
number one i'll give you is two words
pedal tavern
that's what i'm saying
if you want to get an airbnb and make it
on a nice fancy weekend
john
yeah can't take this guy anywhere all
right
no pedal taverns john
you might be a redneck if your
bachelorette party is on a pedal tavern
or you might live in nashville john
you know or you might have come to
nashville yeah those things are a blight
on our city uh all right so um
wow
1500 bucks what do you make a year
uh about 80.
okay
uh i make my husband makes 20 55. and
we're just working on kicking off our
house but yeah he's more like we do not
need to be
okay you know
alex if i'm thinking alex if i'm you i'm
jumping right in the middle of this and
gonna be just clean and clear and direct
and
honestly i'm rather emotion free
get the list of the names and send them
out and say hey i'm gonna make this
thing i need everybody's money by this
date um otherwise i'm not gonna i'm not
gonna put a forward and then mow me the
money and we'll call it good i mean i
would just i would be that clear about
it right
but in terms of like i haven't talked to
her about it so
you know do i just say like um if you're
responsible for throwing the party and
for pay and for putting the money up
front you don't even need to talk to her
you you need to have the list and you
send it out like john said
now you're not asking mr and miss
manners here because we don't have any
manners we're just telling you how to
get the money yeah yeah yeah okay and i
okay
i i i think be real clear with her and
you here's the deal you're an adult and
you gotta have adult boundaries and if
you're not going to here's what's gonna
happen you're gonna end up putting this
on your own you're going to pay for it
some people are going to pay you back
and you're going to get mad at her
because you didn't have boundaries
don't do that
have all your boundaries up front and
say
if you have to have that conversation do
it i don't think you have to like dave
said i don't think you gotta call her
and say i'm not putting this money on my
no just say give me the list of the
names how long how long have you known
them the the bride
yeah for a while probably
i don't know over 15 years
50 15.
oh okay one side okay i was thinking the
paddle tavern definitely ain't working
um
okay no
i will pay for that one
okay so here's the thing i mean and your
relationship with stems when did y'all
your childhood friends or what
yeah probably
middle school
so if i'm in your shoes and i have a
household income 120 000 bucks if i get
half the money i'll put the other half
in and i'm gonna call it a day a
thousand bucks i love this lady she's my
best friend this is childhood i'm in her
i'm in her wedding i'm made of honor and
you do the best you can to collect it
and you release this
and be chill about it
um but yeah you do get a list of names
and say here's how you venmo it and i
expect you to pay your part and there it
is and be nice and kind and clear
and you don't really have to ask the
bride's permission to do that you're the
one paying for it
that's nothing to do with etiquette or
manners we don't know that this is the
ramsey show
hey it's kelly associate producer and
phone screener for the ramsay show if
you would like to do your debt free
scream live on the show make sure you
visit theramsieshow.com and register we
would love for you to come to nashville
and tell dave your story
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the ramsey show
where debt is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw as the status symbol of
choice i'm dave ramsey your host you
jump in we'll talk about your life and
your money it's a free call at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
that's triple eight eight two five
five
two two five dr john dolone ramsey
personality is my co-host today he is
author of the book
redefining anxiety and it's on sale
right now at ramseysolutions.com for ten
dollars you can also listen to him on
the dr john deloney show millions do
lots of questions come in and great
answers lots of wisdom around mental
health around relationships and
boundaries so we'll be talking about
that this hour as well as your money don
is with us don's going to start this
hour in binghamton new york hey don how
are you
i'm good sir thank you for taking my
call sure
i am trying to change the future of the
next generation of those guys that got
debt-free mortgages paid we own
four acres of land uh we're currently
living in a double wide but we're
changing that into a stick built house
come next summer good um
my wife and i are both in our 60s we're
building a small uh empty nester house
now
we have four grandchildren we want to
leave this property in house two but
they're never good
they might be 20 by the time we pass
and we want to be able to leave it to
them but it's going to have to take care
of itself as far as taxes and everything
until they inherit it
any help there any ideas
make that happen
we've i'm i've put my money in the stock
market um i've got 40 000 in there now
just started investing
less than a year ago
we have 40 000 in there i got
6 000 in a money market that's my
emergency fund
and thanks for mentioning that too
because that that thing saved me here a
short while ago and my wife went in the
hospital for about a week and i had to
dip into that thing for that bill
because i don't like to have debt
somebody taught me that yeah how old are
you how old are you guys don
i'm 63 my wife is 60. how old is the
oldest grandchild
eight
okay they go from four to eight yeah the
same bunch i got i'm 61 my oldest is
eight so there you go
well you're a good man and you have a
wonderful heart to leave a legacy and
property is a there's something
emotional about leaving real estate in
your legacy
yeah i want to leave a family treasure
so to speak something they can keep in
the future
and we're another thing we're doing for
that house is we uh
we have about two acres of uh trees out
here in the ash trees you know uh is
dying that's being eaten up by a bug so
we're taking
all of our ash trees and having them cut
down the amish guys coming in tomorrow
to do it and uh
and have the ash trees taken down sawn
into
lumber for flooring to put in the house
and
one oak tree red oak tree out there
we're going to have cut down made into a
door for the front of the house
so something they can look back at and
say grandma and grandpa left this for us
we want to be able to say that yeah we
want to be able to leave this to them
and
somehow or another have the taxes and
everything taken care of until they can
take it over
so
um you've got such a big heart about
this um
the the
your big heart and your vision and your
dream is colliding with the practical
aspects of doing this deal and um so
having owned a bunch of real estate and
filled with it most of my life um
i wouldn't put the burden
of managing a rental property that i
used to live in if i died on uh
a friend or a relative as the trustee
you could leave the property under trust
for the minor kids and have someone
manage the property be the property
manager
for all this time i wouldn't put someone
through that
for this
i just wouldn't i would just uh if if
you were to die tomorrow
both of you i would just tell them to
sell the thing and get divvy the money
up into trust into the kids names to
take care of them now what i would do
is once they if you live that until
they're grown
and you want to leave it to them
directly after they're grown 20 21
whatever then i i would change my will
to uh leave the property to them at that
point
uh and let them you know let them have
the benefit of that but uh this is not a
family farm it's not been in it's not
hundreds of acres it's been in the
family for eight generations uh it's a
place that you are building on at 60
something years old right now so it
hasn't got a huge history but you got a
lot of heart in it i can hear it the way
you're talking about it
um so i personally
then then what i would do is what i do
with mine now and what you already do
with yours i'd walk the property with
them teach that eight-year-old right now
that you'd use those ash trees for that
um
you know the amish guys are coming in
they're going to help us they're they're
wonderful craftsmen they're going to
help us get these flooring in flooring
in out of this this door here is going
to be from that and let that
eight-year-old 10 year old 12 year old
14 year old walk that property let him
hear the stories from his grandpa's
mouth and uh then he'll replicate that
in his life somewhere someday
if you die before you're before he's old
enough for you to leave it to him but i
wouldn't leave that
on someone and let it be a mess for 10
years
you know that somebody has to screw with
personally i don't know what are you are
you hearing john yeah
why wouldn't you leave it to their
parents is there a gap is there
something that you're concerned about
the way the parents would their parents
would manage it
you're pretty observant
their parents won't speak to us we don't
we're not allowed to see our
grandchildren we haven't eaten them
oh there we go yeah 40 years now
we haven't seen him in full years
we're just hoping that we live long
enough that um
they get old enough and they can make
their
their own minds up and come see us
in a special special place yeah that's
i'm so sorry
i do have a friend that's uh quite
wealthy
um
very very very wealthy i should say and
i've considered
this is an idea tell me yes or no we're
working out
leave it to him
and if i had you know
we got like i say the stocks going
and uh
trying to keep a savings in the money
market and
if i leave enough money for him to
maintain the taxes and stuff he agreed
to it would that be an idea
i i it would be but again i think it's a
burden that's part of your you have this
dream
in your mind of the kids all walking the
fields with you and they've come back
and this whole thing is reconciled and
all of all it's given this home is a is
a
reconnected family yeah and
until that happens
i would have my will that the property
is sold and the money goes into trust
for them that's available to them when
they're 25.
but once there's reconnection then you
can consider
changing that but um
i'm so sorry i'm sorry now i understand
why i was hearing so much heart in it
though
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this
still on baby step number one huh
how'd you guess
with health care costs rising learn how
christian healthcare ministries can help
you make the most out of your budget
visit
chministries.org budget don't worry
it's worth it
[Music]
so when you think of a millionaire what
kind of a job do you picture them having
some kind of high-powered executive
position like a vp or a ceo well here's
the thing only about 15 percent of
millionaires actually have that kind of
job
the reality is the top five careers for
millionaires in america are engineer
accountant teacher manager and attorney
and that's one of the many surprising
things our team found when we conducted
the largest study of millionaires ever
done in north america we studied in
depth over 10 000 millionaires
and how they got there our study also
made it clear that to become a
millionaire you've got to invest wisely
and steadily 78 of the millionaires that
we talked to had a financial
advisor in their corner a trustworthy
financial advisor
now we have trustworthy vetted investing
pros from all over the country that we
have vetted
and they go along with the stuff we
teach they're called smart vester pros
they don't work for us they're our
investment advisors we're not in that
business but we refer you to them
and to get in touch with a smart vista
pro in your area just go to
ramseysolutions.com
smart vester you can sit down with them
get your kids college fund going get
everything over going over the uh
the details of everything
and you'll know what to do to get your
rollover of your old 401 k whatever it
is ramsay solutions.com
smart vester
ben is in charlotte north carolina hi
ben welcome to the ramsay show
hi dave and john i appreciate the time
and appreciate all you guys do sure so
much what's up
um so my lovely wife and i we are saving
to build a home and purchase some land
and through conversations we've had with
realtors and builders
they recommended that we buy the land
first just to curb the increase in land
prices
in this crazy time so
the question that we have is we're
trying to save aggressively to do that
um but
knowing that we will probably purchase
land before we actually build a home
that extra money that we're saving
should we be paying down our mortgage or
should we just be saving all of this
extra money in a savings account
um are you going you're going to buy the
land long before you sell the home you
live in
i don't i don't know how long um the
goal is to start building a home in
about um three years
so it's whenever the a deal comes with
the right property and the right amount
of land i would just save up the money
and buy the land
okay so save it all on a savings account
yeah and then just buy the land um
uh because
you're
the logistics of what you're lining up
the dominoes are too far apart to knock
the other one down
in other words you might buy this land
sooner rather than later and then it
might be another year year and a half
two years before you even break grounds
what you're telling me
potentially yeah and if that's the case
you don't have a place to live because
you got to sell the house to get the
money out to buy the land and i'm not
going to tell you to borrow money to buy
the land
right and that's definitely not our plan
right and so if you put it all into your
house the only way to get the land would
be to sell your house or move into
apartment
yeah which we've done before and with
now we're gonna we're i have three going
on four kids
we don't want to do it again yeah that
sounds less than fun
so yeah i think you just save up
it's a break even you're gonna end up at
the end of the story with your house
sold and all the money that you would
have had in your house or it had in the
land is all going to be in the new house
anyway
yeah that's true so at the end of the
story it's all going to be piled over on
that one pile anyway so you're still
going to get there and you're not going
to add any debt in the process and so
um
you know until you actually do the
construction loan and that kind of stuff
if you do a construction loan so yeah
yeah i'm going to just i think your
advice is good that you've been getting
i would just save and pay cash and buy
the land how many acres have you got um
almost seven okay man that's nice six
yeah it's good that's very nice it's
good a little wiggle room is a good
thing
owen is with us owen is in grand rapids
how are you owen
hi dave how you doing better than i
deserve what's up
um so just a quick question i'm having a
bit of a
a little issue here i'm 20 years old i'm
in college i'm currently studying
aerospace engineering and i'm not really
sure if i want to continue or
drop out and go into the trades
considering i'm about 51 000 in debt at
the moment and
i'm just really not enjoying it
what is it you're not enjoying
um well i i just do not like the classes
i'm taking at all and um
i
really just want to start working and
building up income as soon as possible
since you know i'm a broke college kid
basically
what what about the classes do you not
like you don't like the math you don't
it's not aerospace wasn't what you
thought it was or are you just like
millions of dollars yeah exhausted
um i'm very stressed and exhausted all
the time and uh
i just yeah i'm not a fan of math um and
i'm learning that now
and i'd rather i know i like aviation so
i would you know i if i did do something
like the trades i'd want to go into
probably you know aviation mechanic
um so i'm just not sure what direction i
should go at this point
what year are you in school
um i'm a junior
but i am doing a five-year program so i
still i mean i still have about half to
go
and it's making my stomach hurt thinking
about you know another 50k in debt
okay that's a different subject than my
stomach is hurting because i don't like
math
yeah yeah where what school are you in
uh western michigan okay not that
expensive you can work and not go 50k in
debt
yeah um the problem with that is i i
don't really have time to have a
full-time job at the moment i do work on
the weekends when i can and um that's
been going fine but yes you do you have
more time to work than you've been
working
because you don't need to go 50 grand in
debt to finish you can work your way
through western michigan right um that's
possible mathematically you have that
much time
um there's something else going on here
dude yeah are you okay
uh what do you mean
like i i'm hearing from my colleagues
all my former colleagues from all over
the country that college students are
reaching a
a
mental health breaking point
that they're exhausted i mean i'm fine
you're okay um there definitely is yeah
i'm honestly fine i just there's
definitely is um
college is a lot different now after
covered that's what i mean definitely
that's definitely true yeah
um so i think we're working no play
yeah
yeah
my dude i care too much about the play
but yeah
you've dug yourself a 50 000 hole and
what i've seen
time and time again is students leave
and man making minimum wage it's hard to
pay that fifty thousand dollars off
yeah you'd have to be committed to a
short-term program that you paid for
with cash and not going any more debt
and you'd have to have a really high roi
on it man you don't want to get out
which is
i'm sorry yeah go
you just have you thought about changing
your major to something you like more
um yeah i have
although trades would be a lot cheaper
so that's i have thought about that
though
i have not ruled that out okay the tr
the the language that you're using to
discuss all of this sounds to me
i i'm hearing that you're not running to
the trades you're running from
college
the trades is an escape is the way you
keep describing it
it's not like oh man i'm so passionate
about that i want to go do that i've
always wanted to do that and going to
college was a complete mistake for me i
completely goofed no that none of that
it's more like i hate this place over
here i hate math class i hate the stress
i'm under in the anxiety i'm under and
i'll do almost anything to not do this
anymore and then you're going to find
somebody on the internet that tells you
man welders make 800 000 a year and you
can you know i mean like at some point
dave's exactly right you are you're
running from a problem
not towards whatever you want to do
yeah i think we need to i think you need
to figure out what you can run to
before you run
i'm okay with you quitting college
absolutely okay and i'm okay or with you
changing majors and i'm okay with you
working 50 hours a week and paying your
way the rest of the way through if you
want to do that and change to
engineering or probably more math there
but um anyway but but uh i want you to
have a something you're going to
rather than just
from go meet with the college counseling
center you've paid into it and they're
there for this exact purpose see if they
can help you guide guide you through
this hang on i'm going to send you a
copy of ken coleman's career assessment
and maybe that'll give you some insights
too
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today in the lobby of ramsey
solutions on the debt-free stage lisa is
with us hi lisa how are you hi dave it's
so great to see you hi john so great to
see you i'm so thankful to be here well
we're honored to have you where do you
live i'm from uh houston texas beach
town yeah texas h town well good to have
you and how much debt have you paid off
girl oh dave 264
thousand dollars on a single income and
i am waited seven years to walk through
your doors wow you've been working on
this seven years seven years and what
was your range of income during this
seven years i'm a registered nurse and
it was eight between 83 and 93. good for
you well done you've had a boring few
years a lives the last couple years huh
it's been wild let me tell you yes thank
you so much for
uh
being on the front lines yeah yeah
feeling that gap for all of us so uh 264
000 was that your house
well part of it was um i did something
kind of interesting i sold my house at
the end of my journey i was maybe two to
three months out so about 164 000
was
just the regular you know credit cards
cars and oh of course dave i had some
payday loans
and
but about 102 was my house and i decided
to go ahead and sell it
towards the end of the journey because i
knew it would accelerate my journey and
i would be able to have my six-month
emergency fund and i would be able to
start my 15 investing and that kind of
thing so i sold it towards the end when
the real estate market was really
booming in houston wow and it ended up
being a fantastic decision for me and
i um i i'm so happy dave i cannot even
find anybody that i have to pay
i
i am so
thankful
good for you i am so thankful
it is just the best best feeling in in
the world and and yes it was a lot of
work and yes it was there were some some
things that happened on the journey that
i wanted to share with you that i think
even a lot of your listeners will be
able to appreciate and um i had decided
that all the way through this journey
that i was going to keep god first
and in the journey i
would budget grocery money
i would take it right out of my budget
and i would go down into the third ward
of houston and i would find families
that were in desperate need of food
throughout this whole journey i did this
and i would go door-to-door
to families down there and i would feed
them
and
i believed that god delivered me out of
this huge mess this huge hardship
because i honored him and i did what the
word of god says in giving
and
the other thing that i want to share
with you is right when i um
right when i had my um
uh
right when i was just about uh ready to
get out of debt
i had a
ac company come in and let me know that
i had to have the whole ac replaced so i
was just about ready to land the plane
just about ready to become debt free and
i got handed a 10
000
ac bill and i just stood in my kitchen
and i looked at it and i thought what
would what would dave do
in this situation and
the the solution was just attack it like
every other bill every other debt and i
learned from it
when you have a setback don't step back
because god has your comeback on the way
wow that'll preach
good for you girl good for you very well
done
very well done now that you did this
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
the first thing i would say to him is to
get organized
uh
the first thing i would say to him is to
get organized and that's what i did i as
i organized my debt smallest to largest
as you teach
but the other thing
i would say to him is on the journey
there are
gonna there are setbacks there are
hardships like what happened with an ac
unit
and
to not get discouraged to keep pushing
keep going and um and i and i also feel
like um giving in the journey is is
critical i do believe that god delivered
me out of this mess
when i was when i was helping the poor
yeah and i believe that you know you've
done such a great job teaching us
uh the word of god in your work and i i
listened to you also i
another thing i did was i listened to
your podcast
an hour going into work and an hour
coming out of work for a long long time
and i read the total money makeover
twice
so i just made sure that i was educating
myself with everything that you're a
force of nature girl
i mean there's no question are you are
getting after it yes definitely god
delivered you and god bless you and but
what he did was he multiplied your
efforts and you put forth an extreme
amounts of effort
and uh you know you weren't sitting at
home waiting on roast duck to fly in the
window you went duck shooting i'm so
proud of you
well done very very well done very cool
yeah i i suspect anything you set your
hand to is going to occur
yeah it's very very well done good stuff
yeah just i i'm just i'm proud of you
congratulations thank you so much john
thank you so much and the work that you
do and together the team that you have
has i i just celebrate the victory dave
with you and all of your team because
your hard work is what's educating the
public to become debt free and to to
live a life of freedom and happiness
i'm so happy now and when i walked
through those doors i waited seven years
to thank you wow
and i'm and i'm thanking you now well
thank you you're inspiring you're you're
inspiring i'm so proud of you very very
well done good stuff
good stuff okay if somebody asks how you
get out of debt what do you tell them
the very first thing i'm going to tell
them is to put god first in their
finances um the other thing i want to
share with them is you should be
organized a while ago yes be organized
and to really follow your steps because
they work and i also know that um
in the journey that uh that they not get
discouraged and i was on a long journey
i wasn't on a two or three year journey
i was on a long one because it was a lot
of money for one income
but i would i'm so thankful now that i
did it i'm so grateful to you for
educating me and it's so great to
finally meet my mentor oh bless your
heart who is your biggest cheerleader
i think you no no i'm talking about in
your life
sitting right next to me uh my
sister-in-law carol no go carol yes
my brother mike who's a phenomenal money
manager
and my nephew dean that is an even more
phenomenal money manager so good people
in your corner very much good stuff well
we got a copy of the every uh baby steps
millionaires for you that's the next
chapter in your story for sure the book
comes out january the 11th we're going
to give you a copy today an advanced
reader copy and also a copy of total
money makeover for you to give away and
get someone else started on their
journey i got a feeling that
you will be discussing this with someone
it sounds like that's the way it goes so
i'm so proud of you waiting way to go
hero you killed it absolutely so much
lisa is in houston texas 264
thousand dollars paid off in seven years
making
83-93 count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream three
two
one and may the glory go to god
i'm dead free
[Applause]
so great you can uh never mess up
feeding the poor nope
you can never mess up feeding hungry
children nope it's uh there's never a
time you look back and go oh well that
was a mistake shouldn't have done that
one that one doesn't come up that
doesn't come up and uh it turns loose
things in your spirit generosity is an
amazing thing it causes people to be
highly attractive
generous people are highly attractive
and grateful people she's she's one of
the most grateful people i've had an
opportunity to meet this week yes amen
way to go lisa you're a hero very very
well done
this
is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day first
thessalonians 5 11 therefore encourage
one another and build each other up
just as in fact you are doing
bill bradley said leadership is
unlocking people's potential to become
better
john's with us in boulder colorado hi
john welcome to the ramsay show
hi david john thank you for the time
today sure um i got a question that
might be covered in your your upcoming
book i already pre-ordered it
but i figured i'd try to get in early um
i have a question that regards to your
favorites math and multiple choice
regarding employee stock purchase and
rsu's
i'm on baby steps 456 and really trying
to get it done i think i can reach step
seven by 2026.
um you know this part but um my employer
apple offers in place i purchase that i
can buy into two for two periods
for 15 discount on the stock
from the lowest of either the start or
end of the period i'm doing 10 of my
gross salary using that post-tax money
um so in a year i'm putting roughly 13
000
into this espp if i go and buy that
stock at the lowest from the start of
this period that'd be about 105 shares
which would turn the
13 000 into about 18 000.
the
multiple choice portion of it is um
sell immediately pay no short-term taxes
on the gain
um
b sell in a year
with uh long-term taxes
uh c an arbitrary date um or b or d
not doing espp all together and just
chunk it towards my mortgage
gotcha okay
well to start with you need to be doing
15 of your income towards retirement not
counting this discussion are you
yes i am okay
and so this is play money beyond that
and the only the only downside is do we
put it on the stock
and mess with it or do we put it into
the house and pay the house down
um yeah here's the thing in general i
mean you mentioned the company so that
that does change the discussion slightly
because apple's track record is
unbelievable
um but the uh
99 of the time
just about any other company you
mentioned and it i don't think it's true
of apple but it could be
if you look at a 52-week high and a
52-week low
of a single stock
almost always there's a 15 movement up
and down
and so a 15 discount is what everyone
gets on their company when they're doing
an employee stock purchase
that's standard okay everybody gets it's
not it's not unique to your company and
and so my point is you could buy
something and it could drop 15 as easy
goes up 15 in one year and so the 15
discount does not make it a great buy in
99 of the cases now apple pretty much
has gone up into the right so
uh might be an exception i don't know
uh if you're going to play with this
because it's apple
um uh you're not going to do it because
it's 15 discounted you're going to do it
because it's apple and because of the
track record and the history of it being
up and to the right uh the second thing
you want to do is if you're going to be
in any single stock
i would not ever have more than 10 of
your net worth tied up in that
that way if the whole thing goes
completely belly up
for whatever reason my mom worked at
enron it does there you go it doesn't
affect you yeah because there is no
sure thing and so the lack of
diversification
even if it's in the best company of
whatever best companies and they have
more money than the country of egypt
which is actually true
um so you know then you know even if
that's the case
uh you still don't want to bet much more
than 10 of your net worth on there so if
you want to play with this because
you're enamored with it
um
don't let don't let it be more than ten
percent of your net worth
personally i have not followed that
direction my personal path and what i've
taught and what you hear me answer the
question over and over again is no don't
do employee stock until you get your
house paid off and put everything
towards your house above 15 of your
income going into retirement and that's
the standard
ramsey way of doing things and that
works 100 of the time this could work
and you could make some money on it in
the future i would not hold it less than
a year if you're going to hold it less
than a year i just wouldn't screw with
it um but if you're going to hold it
long term don't allow that account to
end up being more than 10 of your net
worth
and uh and don't
just don't hit your wagon to a single
stock
because that's always going to bring
back pain into your life later at some
point
it gets scary elizabeth's in louisville
kentucky hi elizabeth welcome to the
ramsay show hi dave i have a two-fold
question for you fellas today if you
don't mind i'll try to make it quick
okay
my family has had two major life changes
i have a family member that cannot eat
or process nutrition so she's on vein
nutrition which is ten thousand dollars
a bag
my dad had a major stroke and is looking
at nursing home placement and has no
long-term care insurance
i know the answer that would be one of
the answers is long-term care insurance
but i'm i'm also
have a dilemma in the way i'm feeling
they're
getting the same care um paying
thousands upon thousands 13 000 a month
out of pocket and the person down the
hall is paying nothing so
as a christian and because i trust what
you
have to say how should i feel about that
or do you have any advice for me
on how i should process through that
well i pay millions of dollars in taxes
and the person on welfare doesn't
and i pay less than dave and we share
the same road and the same police
officers
true the person down the the person
that's in a nursing home on medicaid
medicare
it's medicare is our medicaid is that's
welfare that's welfare
you have to be indigent you have to be
poor
if you have assets to pay for your
nursing home the government will not pay
for your nursing home
because you're not poor
yeah i know it's sad that they could
take everything though no they're not
taking everything
any more than a restaurant takes
everything if you go over there and buy
food at the restaurant yeah they're
providing a service and you're paying
them for it
they're not robbing him feels so bad
they're not robbing him
he has worked his whole life to be cared
for and taken care of and his assets
will provide that care for him
and it's not um
you know
who they're taking from is you
because you're not going to get the
inheritance
because he's going he's going to spend
it on himself before he dies
yeah and my mom my mom is in in good
health
yeah that's bad yeah
but but the truth is i mean you're he's
you know so uh what i'm gonna do is shop
the nursing home experience get the best
care for the least dollar like we would
with anything that we purchase
and um
not just assume that but the person down
the hall that's on welfare doesn't
affect whether i go get a job
no
and i'm not going to give them access to
the last few remaining years i have with
my dad i'm not going to choose
bitterness and choose anger and choose
resentment i'm not going to do that am i
going to give that away to somebody i
don't know
i don't know their life their
circumstances their story i know
anything about what's going on there i'm
going to be grateful that my dad was so
good with his money that he can pay for
his care right now even though it's it's
it's liquidating it's going fast right
but he worked hard taking care of it and
i'm going to enjoy the time with him
well what i'm going to do is negotiate
and you know manage every bit of this
money you're purchasing a service just
like you're purchasing having a car
repaired or
um i don't know anything you pay for a
service you pay for the service and uh
nursing home care is a legitimate
service they're not they're not robber
barons they didn't they're not stealing
they're not making you do this um and
you may choose depending on the what his
uh needs are with the stroke you may
choose to hire private care in home it
might be cheaper might be cheaper uh and
it might be higher quality care
uh if you've got that ability uh require
some more management maybe on your part
because you can manage the people
involved
but um you can look at that as an option
too and um find different ways to do
this because if it's thirteen thousand
dollars a month that's that that's not
that's not
shouldn't be that much yeah that's
that's high hiking so um but uh but i
yeah
it's um
it nursing home evokes a different place
in us to where people feel that like
they're being stolen from and you're not
and often our own grief and pain we look
around for somebody around us to cast
that upon you know right yeah don't do
that you know sit in it and choose joy
yeah
thanks for calling hon i'm sorry you
guys are going through this that's hard
dr john dolany good to show today good
job to ben and kelly in the booth i am
dave ramsey your host will be back with
you before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
have a friend or family member that
needs a daily dose of ramsey advice in
their life let them know about the
ramsey call of the day podcast it's a
quick hit of advice about life and money
in under 10 minutes check out the ramsey
call of the day podcast wherever you
listen to podcasts
[Music]
you